I'm here with the Fabiano's Coronas
second roost I'm Qasim John of coming
from was back east on roost and first of
all welcome back to San Luis you've been
here a few times tell us a bit about the
work of a second during one of these
like big events well it's not easy to
begin with mainly it's a sleepless work
it's tiring work but sometimes it also
is gratifying work because you find some
ideas which student gets to play this is
a very nice feeling but in general it's
just early hours and late hours as well
so mainly just looking for novelties
speaking of ideas it seems like in
pretty much all of these games Fabiano
was ahead after the opening at least he
knew what to do could you say that he he
definitely got what he wanted well some
of this is the residue of the wall
championship work some of the ideas that
we found with ball championship match
finally getting to play them so yeah
there's things that we didn't get
against Magnus now we're trying to hit
other players targeting other players
but some of the things like for instance
in the game against Magnus's ideas
Bishop disease which is new I found it
just the morning before the game so it's
like a mixture of some you know old
baggage you have and some new ideas
after this event Fabiano is going to
play a match against the one garry
kasparov who you know quite well did you
ever think that you're going to see
Fabiano play match he played a few games
beforehand but a match against Garry
Kasparov or this was just like
unconceivable well it's interesting
first of all because I actually think
that well depending on how he trains
before the match I think Eric as part of
can still be a very dangerous opponent I
think the last time he played this kind
of match was it again stupid love here
maybe a year ago he looked a bit rusty
but maybe figures you know some training
game scene maybe he plays some games
online I think Gary can be dangerous and
this will be interesting to see and
finally you've played a little bit in
the past year and I'm sure you plan on
playing a bit more what do you prefer
better playing or seconding basically
it's funny it's every time I come to
tournament like this and wake up early
and I think
my god I would rather play myself and
then when I end up playing myself I
think oh my god this is so stressful
yeah I never want to do this again
so I guess both of these jobs are not
easy playing is more interesting but in
a way coaching Fabiana is more
gratifying because it's on a whole
different level musically when I play
myself I don't have to prepare against
players like Carson or onion so in a way
I'm grateful for this opportunity to be
to kind of remain on the top level even
if as a coach I can definitely find
myself as well in in your answer thank
you very much roost I mean good luck -
favi on